嗨KRISTAN UCCELLO: Hi.
My name is Krispy My name's Krispy.
I am a developer promoting the relationship of the foundry development team. I'm a Developer Advocate on the Cast Developer Relations team.
In this DevBytes video I will discuss In this DevBytes video, I will discuss
About Google Cast TV stick content and Google Cast receivers and how development
How the development content works with the receiving device works with Cast receiver devices.
For this video I assume that you have already for this video, I'm assuming you're already
Familiar with the developer console familiar with the Cast developer console.
If not, please check the developer console documentation If not, please review the developer console documentation.
Now let's see what the receiver application is, let's take a look at what a receiver application is.
The receiving application is just a single-page HTML5 application. The terminal receiver applications are single-page HTML5 apps.
It loads from a web URL that are loaded from a network URL
And run on a special version of Chrome and execute on a special version of Chrome.
The receiver application runs on the receiver device.
For example, Chrome Cast TV stick like a Chrome Cast.
Elements such as Button links and alert Elements such as buttons, links, and alerts
Since there is no mouse or keyboard device available has been disabled since there's no mouse or keyboard
Will be disabled input available.
All interactions associated with the recipient application All interactions with a running Cast receiver application
The messages generated by the sender application happen through messages sent by a Cast sender app.
To illustrate this interaction model To illustrate this interaction model,
Let's take a look at how a receiver application is launched. Let's take a look at how a Cast receiver application is launched.
The situation is that such a tank receiver applications are launched
When a sender runs an application when a Cast sender application running
On a sender device such as a phone, tablet, or computer when running on a sender device such as a mobile phone tablet or computer
It tells a receiver device that it needs to launch an application tells a receiver device that it wants to launch an application.
What is the application to launch depends on What that application is depends on the application ID
The application ID provided by the sender when requesting the use of the recipient device that the sender provides when requesting to use the receiver device.
The recipient device will look for the Google service and The receiver device will look up the application ID using
Load the corresponding recipient application ID a Google service and load the corresponding receiver
Application associated with it.
Once the receiver application is loaded, Once the receiver application is loaded,
It can start from the connected senders it can start processing messages from the connected sender
Processing information applications.
As a developer you can choose As a developer, you have options when
The type of sender involved in the receiver application initiated comes to the type of receiver application launched by a sender.
An application ID is an application ID that is a unique ID for a receiver application on the Cast Developer Console.
The register of the receiving program that you get when you register a receiver
The only ID app in the Cast developer console.
You can register an application ID at cast.google.com/publish. You can register an application ID at cast.google.com/publish.
There are three types of receiver applications There are three types of receiver applications,
Both of them require the developer console two of which require registration using
To register the remaining one, you don't need the Cast developer console, and one that does not.
The one that is not needed is called Default Media Receiver The one that doesn't is called the Default Media Receiver,
All it does is play simple media and all it does is play simple media.
No styles have no custom interface and no application ID No styling, no customization, and no application ID.
There is no way to change its behavior. There's no way to modify its behavior.
Styled Media Receiver application The Styled Media Receiver application
You need to register and allow some custom require registration and allow for some customization.
This is for simple media playback It's for playback of simple media.
More features than the former. More on this in a moment.
Custom Receivers is a Custom Receivers are applications
Need to register and for the advanced media player or that require registration and are for building advanced media
Players or other types of TV applications like games developed in other forms of TV applications like games.
A Styled Media Receiver allows the sender's application A Styled Media Receiver to allow a sender application
Play media on a Cast device without having to play media on a Cast device without needing
Create your own custom receiver application to create your own Custom Receiver application.
You can customize the color of Styled Media Receiver. You can customize the Styled Media Receiver color
Plan and branding by providing your own CSS during registration by providing your own CSS during the registration process.
Styled Media Receiver is a great way The Styled Media Receiver is a great way
To start building the Google Cast app to get started building Google Cast applications.
Using Styled Media Receiver means Using the Styled Media Receiver
Developers can focus on the sender application developer can focus their efforts on the sender application
Interaction without having to build a custom receiver interaction without having to build a custom receiver.
Create a Styled Media Receiver Creating a Styled Media Receiver is
Registering with the Cast Developer Console should be as easy as registering for an application ID
It's as easy to use the program ID as the program developer console.
Styled Media Receiver is the application of The Styled Media Receiver is the best option
The best choice when you don't need to take advantage of advanced media features if the application does not need to utilize advanced media
For example, adaptive streaming media playback function DRM and playback capabilities such as adaptive streaming, DRM,
Embedded captioning or authentication, etc. closed captioning, or authentication.
Custom Receiver application is Custom Receiver applications are the way
If you want to control to go if you want to have control
The best choice for all aspects of the behavior of your application is over all aspects of the behavior of your application.
With Custom Receivers you can support the protocol namespace with Custom Receivers, you can support protocol name spaces
Not just the media and you can build a rich experience for users just beyond media and build rich experiences for your users.
You have full control over the presentation, interactions, and more.
Use the GoogleCast Receiver SDK Using the Google Cast receiver SDK,
You can build an HTML5 application, you can build an HTML5 application, hook
Incorporate various activities occurring in the Cast receiving information system into the various events that are fired within the Cast Receiver
And on the simple media player, Message System, and build complex behaviors
Build complex behaviors beyond simple media playback.
Cast Receiver API provides developers with The Cast Receiver APIs provides ways for developers
Create a method for TV-rich applications to build rich applications targeting the TV space.
You can use the media player library to you can utilize the Cast media player library
Establish an application that uses adaptive streaming media to build media applications that use adaptive streaming.
Like HLS MPEG DASH smooth streaming, etc. HLS, MPEG DASH, smooth streaming, and more.
They can also handle authentication issues and use DRM They can also handle authentication and use DRM.
In order to load the receiver application to In order to load a receiver application onto a Cast device
Register on Cast equipment, you want to be in Cast while developing, register the receiver devices
The recipient device used by the developer console, you wish to use in the Cast developer console.
For an unpublished receiver application For an unpublished receiver application,
Only registered devices are only registered Cast devices will
Capable of loading the receiver application to able to load the receiver application.
And during the development process, the receiver device As well, during development, the receiver device
Need to disclose its serial number will need to expose its serial number.
This feature can be enabled using the Chrome Cast Settings app. This can be enabled using the Chrome Cast setup application.
Simply select the Cast device and enable the "Send serial" when checking for updates
Simply select the device and enable the sending serial number number when checking for updates" option.
When you publish your application, when you publish your application,
Any receiving device can load your app. Any Cast receiver device can load your app.
Now I have introduced some basic settings for development. Now that I've covered some of the basics of setting up
Let's look at some code for development, let's have a look at some code.
A very basic custom receiving application in a few lines of code. In a few lines of code, a very basic Custom Receiver
Can be built to play simple media applications can be built that plays simple media.
First we load the receiver's API First, we load the receiver APIs.
Then we make sure we have a video element and some media elements. Then we ensure that we have a video element, some media
For playback of video music, etc. element to play back video, music, et cetera.
Once the window has started loading it will determine the media element Once the window onload is fired, identify the media element
And create a media processor to handle the sender and create a Cast media manager to handle the sender
Communication and various media events communication and media events.
Then get an instance of the receiving processor, Then get an instance of the Cast receiver manager, which
This example is responsible for communication with the Google Cast system is responsible for communicating with the Cast system.
And command the system to start, let the receiver know and tell it to start, which lets the receiver device know
The application is loaded and ready to process the message that the application is loaded and ready to process sender messages.
Here you can build additional application logic from here, you can build up additional application logic.
If you do this, you may want to know how to debug the receiver code. And you do, you might want to know how to debug your receiver code.
Fortunately, the application for debugging the receiver is very simple, it's very simple to debug receiver applications.
You can connect to the device debugger You can connect to a device debugger
Just open the receiver registered in Chrome on your computer on a registered receiver by opening Chrome on a computer
And go to the IP address of the receiver device on port 9222 and go to the IP address of the receiver device on port 9222.
You can get the IP address of the receiver device using using the Chrome Settings app.
The IP address on the receiver, the Chrome Cast setup app.
The debugger has full DOM manipulation and JavaScript console support. The debugger has full DOM manipulation and JavaScript console support.
To keep a log between sessions, click on the gear icon in the lower right corner. To keep logs between sessions, click the gear icon
And check the box next to it in the lower right and check the box next to "Preserve
Save the log log upon navigation while navigating."
We are excited to see the programs you developed with Google Cast. We are very excited to see what you build with Google Cast.
In order to keep you going, we provide a lot of resources to get you going, we're providing a number of resources.
You will find more details about the Google SDK. You can discover more details about the Google Cast SDK.
Please visit developers.google.com/cast at developers.google.com/cast.
The design checklist will guide you over a long period of time. The design checklist will go a long way in guiding you
Create a great second screen application down the path to creating great second screen applications.
You can find the sender example and the receiving application example You can find sample senders and sample receiver apps
At github.com/googlecast. at github.com/googlecast.
Upload your question using Stack Overflow and post your questions on Stack Overflow and tag them with Google-cast.
In the future DevBytes show we will go deeper into In future DevBytes, we will dive deeper
Learn about the sender SDK and receiver SDK for each platform prepared by each platform and the Cast receiver SDK.
Join the Google Developer Community on Google+ and you can get the Join the Google Cast developer community on Google+ for pro
Professional guidance and share your experience tips and share your experiences.
It’s up to you to create a great Google Cast app. It’s now up to you to go out and create great Google Cast
The best time is the receiver application.
I wish you a happy Happy casting.